l'homme dans cette vidéo est le patron
du groupe paramiltérieux ce Wagner
entouré de marmite tenant un drapeau
russe il affirme que son groupe vient de
prendre le contrôle total de la ville de
backmouth situé dans l'est de l'Ukraine
puis que l'on appelle le cuisinier de
Poutine assurant ensuite que la ville
sera complètement fouillée que des
positions défensives y seront établies
avant de transférer le 25 mai à l'armée
russe le contrôle de backmouth
une affirmation aussitôt contredite par
keV par l'entremise de la vie ce
ministre de la Défense qui prétend que
l'armée ukrainienne contrôle toujours
certaines installations même si la
situation y est critique sur la question
empirique est-ce qu'il y a vraiment pris
la ville de barthout le professeur de
nicarel doute pour sa part de la
véracité des propos du patron du groupe
Wagner qu'il invite à prendre avec un
grain de sel il y a des signes qui
en fait irait dans l'autre direction qui
pourrait signaler que le vent est en
train de tourner et que l'Ukraine sera
peut-être en mesure vraiment de faire
des percer à l'est si les deux camps
avancent des informations
contradictoires ils ont néanmoins subi
d'importantes pertes à Bac mot au cours
des derniers mois faisant de cette ville
un territoire dévasté transformé par les
bombardements quotidiens où vivaient en
paix autrefois quel que 70 000 habitants
ici elles disent